[Música]
seguramente muitos nós já pensamos qual
é o propósito da nossa vida e para
alguns travou voluntariado para outra
família ver os filhos que se fez
acompanhar e aconselhar os meus pais em
vencer pra outra estrada defender causas
maiores do que o próprio mas tenho
certeza que muitas destas alta amanhã o
trabalho
nós encontramos propósito no trabalho
que fazemos
gostamos do que fazemos nos temos da
equipe onde estamos
vemos também naquilo e na inovação tem
uma uma diretora que ao mais alto nível
criativa da espaço deixando voar e eu
chego ao final do dia com aquela
sensação de missão cumprida
o sentido realização e vigo mesmo isso
tem e faz sentido pra mim mas para
alguns outros quando pensamos em
trabalho e quando pensamos em propósito
é história já não é banhista
e quando nós perguntamos então qual é o
propósito que o trabalho traz temos que
pensar lá atrás e nos ao nosso baldo
menores e deserdado sim eu lembro
daquela fase inicial do acolhimento e
naquela fase de integração em que me
apresentaram a todas as pessoas da
empresa em que cursavam e meus comigo
partilhava omissão que tenham pra mim
estava muito claro os objetivos que
desafiava o texto e havia conversas
permanentes então isabel como está a
correr trabalho quais são as suas
expectativas e este momento serão
importantes porque o sentia sintonia com
o lema da empresa queira ver a mudança
acontecer e temos cor também que houve
uma altura em que tivemos que fazer uma
mudança no armazém imensa referências um
trabalho exaustivo
lutamos todos entramos em bando durante
aquelas 48 horas e conseguimos lugar é
que o que alguns achavam impossível
nós chegamos vai fizemos e ainda no colo
mas sempre pensar no meu paul morris e
não ocorre com os contagiamos e queremos
via positiva e maneira com nossos feita
fui citamos em ser a conseguimos fomos
capazes
mudamos as todas as referências do
armazém e nem sequer criamos grandes
constrangimentos com os clientes
mas o que eu vou pensando é que nesta
jornada que o trabalho envolvendo -
conversas é que o que inicialmente em
fazia sintonizar vai acontecendo - vezes
aquela opinião que viam tantas vezes no
início mas que acho que podemos melhorar
as reclamações têm de que alguma
sugestão pra atendimento aos clientes
acho que podemos aqui enfim tocada
eficiência do processo produtivo é
aquelas conversas tornam se menos
sistemáticas aquelas conversas acontecem
menos vezes e até quando eu dou a minha
opinião
veja se um certo que virá olhos plata
ela já não há paciência assim tava e
depois falamos sobre isso também podemos
pois vivemos e que o vai atrofiando vai
atrofiando eu vou sentindo provavelmente
vou criando aqui alguma desconexa são
com aquele clima que a empresa tinha com
o qual eu me identificava tinha muito a
ver com os temas da mudança e vou
criando essa disconnect virada com o meu
propósito mas este brilho no olhar pra
mim é tão importante eu vou buscá-lo
outros contextos vôos calcando
explicações a mills carenciadas e vou
buscá lo quando eu vejo que aumentou sua
confiança porque finalmente no final do
segundo período consegui a positiva
matemática buscá-lo no drive tem na
seção de paz que nos juntamos e que
maquiou sábado conseguimos melhorar toda
aquela sala no bem estar e toda aquela
sala refeição do lar de idosos e que
pintamos e que chamos as portas que nos
queixamos também todos
mas no final do dia quando chegam aqui o
aconchego do olhar de deus e o que eu
sinto quando faço estas atividades fora
do trabalho é que o alcance da minha mão
e eu toco neste impacto o cinto fato
faça esta defesa e eu sinto que dou o
melhor de mim e claramente segundo
melhor dos outros então mas porque nós
temos que fazer isso nestes contextos e
não fazemos isto e não voltamos a fazer
este vai ver que nós temos não voltemos
a trazê lo também para o trabalho porque
não porque nós não voltemos a
conectar-se isso - por não serão tão
importante por que é que nós não
trazemos esta minha opção de mim mesma
para o trabalho por que não eu quero
também uma vez que estava no projeto
numa empresa relacionado com o tema do
desempenho da avaliação do desempenho e
abstração tinha colocado com o tema
estratégico todo nossa metodologia
estamos há empenho sentiam que o museu
que tinham era muito ágil enfim uma
série de indicadores
tenho umas reuniões que nós fazíamos mas
que o clareamento não cumpriu o
propósito da empresa então desafiaram os
é nós equipa de gestão pessoas e passou
ser aquela é nossa missão
envolvemos nós tínhamos uma colega que
na altura estava a fazer uma porta do
céu foi recolher imensa informação do
mercado
não temos informação da concorrência
conversamos com os colegas internamente
para perceber o que estava a funcionar a
união nesse sistema de avaliação do
desempenho e apresentamos a nossa
proposta nos 300 que era um tema
estratégico e assim foi e chegou via
daniel ilustrador muito tempo mas eu
sentia e algum desconforto nenhum mas
enfim pensar que somos nós que não
estamos a ter esta capacidade de porton
nesta crença que temos
estávamos cheios de entusiasmo super
contagiados e pra mim era um tema
importante porque estava a trabalhar há
pouco tempo na empresa e sentia que os
colegas com quem nós falávamos sobre
esse tema desempenho dos 8º e nós
confiança e acima tudo esperança de que
nós vimos agora conseguir de alguma
maneira contagiar resolver o tema do
desempenho que sempre antena
constrangedor nas empresas
no final da reunião o senador frei citou
nomes
- os paraguaios pelo nosso projeto
estava muito vai muito sustentado que
tinha de facto imensa informação do
mercado altamente alinhado com nossa
cultura organizacional
demos os parabéns por termos feito um
trabalho onde ouvimos os colaboradores e
os coelhos
temos conseguido trazer as evidências
que eu queria que eu tenha a perceção
que aquela cirurgia não funcionava muito
bem não tinha a certeza e no fundo nós
tínhamos trazido essa certeza mas com
nós sabíamos que estávamos numa fase
também dentro da sinalização da empresa
e nesse sentido
precisávamos colocar os nossos recursos
nessas interações do céu deve abrir um
mercado que estava com oportunidades mas
eles gente e nós tínhamos que nos
depositaram nessas mercados e portanto
obrigada a equipa ana
enfim em momento oportuno depois nós
falaremos sobre este projecto e o que
nós sentimos todos naquele momento foi
que alguma coisa se partiu de dentro de
nós
pragmaticamente racionalmente
nós entendemos que esse tema da
internacionalização teve a autenticidade
do hotel e só que nós sabíamos que
estava acontecendo mas dentro de nós o
desalento foi tão grande tão grande que
nós conseguimos da reunião é nossa
confiança está em baixa e porque
sentimos também que temos desenvolvido
os colegas que tinham apostado em nós e
que nos tinham dado voz para termos um
em baixas doses do processo o que nós
fizemos foi o carinho de entrar na
sinalização
mas aquilo que nós deveríamos ter feito
era claramente consolidado encontrar o
momento de voltar é conectar e voltar a
partilhar esse tema
a unidade não é passividade unidade era
conseguir ter esta chuva o movimento pra
ver qual é o momento de voltar a falar e
com alongamento voltar a colocar isso na
agenda da administração e dizer olha o
fato não estamos a trabalhar o tema
desempenho continua a ver que falta de
cuidados
esta falta de cuidado alimenta a
toxicidade e toxicidade tem tendência é
nos desligar
nós não fizemos isso olhando para trás
com fios a viver porque poderíamos ter
feito e nós podemos claramente voltar a
encontrar estes momentos
nos fazem ser mais conectados
é fundamental que isso aconteça por
claramente assim nós conseguimos ter
toda essa capacidade de partilhar
informação nesse sentido e também o fato
de nós temos programas onde senta aqui
na minha secretária centro da minha
secretária precisa que o que eu faço
percebemos porque é que o meu trabalho
impacto no seu trabalho e porque fato
quando tropeça aquela informação a
quinta feira e tu tá sempre discutir
comigo não é por dispositivos minha mas
depois a 6ª linha as etes e que já não
está cá aceita nem eu tenho que passar
aquela informação para transitários para
conseguir com que nosso cliente receba
mercadoria tempo e quando nós temos esta
capacidade conhecer melhor e partilhar
esse conhecimento e tornar único esses
fatos seja melhor
a partilha de conhecimento e antena que
deva acontecer não só como nós fazemos o
acolhimento e integração mas crescer
algo permanente e que nos inquieta
porque esta aprendizagem permanente
também traz um certo brilho no olhar
claro que conhecer as diferentes
realidades não significa que nós vamos
guiados por um propósito comum
falta aqui o tema da coesão falta aqui o
tema daquilo que nos a grega como
indivíduos daquilo que nos grega que nos
faz ter equipa e nesse sentido as
empresas trabalham banhos temas têm
building e também lembro teambuilding
que nós vivemos em que vivemos um
rafting inês castings tínhamos que fazer
uma investida pelo rio mas também
tínhamos quem treinados menos subir nas
montanhas de ser assim nas caladas mais
fugir nosos nossa administrador tenha
certeza disso
em uma dessas siglas mais divino rosa
sim é o nosso chefe de manutenção é
perceber o desconforto do nosso
administrador
depois de manobrar a seres noturnos e
deu assim o ombro para que elas pudessem
apoiar e aquela surpresa com que o fez
e aquela empatia que o momento calou a
voz de todos nós
nada voltou mais a ser igual porque nós
sentimos ele foi aquela intimidade e o
que era a força ea austeridade o nosso
administrador de repente
sentiu a tranquilidade alguém que num
outro contexto tem uma força que faz com
que seja
e neste sentido em termos de práticas de
gestão e de liderança e de equipas e
nesse sentido nós temos este propósito é
fundamental nós temos o primeiro erro
que é foco
se eu quero trabalhar a partir do
conhecimento via fazê lo porque de facto
hoje tem nós em quetta nos e fartos
vibrar o olhar e se eu quero trabalhar a
coesão claramente este é um primeiro e
se que eu desejo
mas isso deve acontecer com freqüência
não é uma vez que eu faço isso na gestão
mas viu fazer com claridade freqüência
noel nos vezes mas a pertinência com que
eu faço porque esta freqüência que nos
vai permitir ganhar essa
sustentabilidade e perceber que não foi
só no primeiro momento para morar juntos
mas claramente nós queremos criar e
construir uma vida em conjunto e esta
freqüência e taka de vida também estão a
fazer bem uma vez não será difícil mantê
los no topo e que fato mal sabia ele que
é preciso coragem
nós não estávamos aqui inventar e o
terceiro e se tem a ver com feedback é
importante um irmãozinho se aquilo que
estou a fazer e rotinas que estou a ter
estão a criar impacto no foco que eu
quero ver acontecer
e este saiu ponto que este sair o fbi a
imensa as metodologias de gestão e meus
queimas de utilização
bela se colocar um conjunto de práticas
e de aplicativos para nos darem este
feedback para os dizeres taco verbais
não está a correr mas o que eu creio
mesmo que o melhor aplicativo é nós nos
sentarmos e dizermos e entanto mas isto
faz sentir por aqui por claramente
quando nós fazemos nós nutrimos laço de
confiança
[Aplausos]